monarchy actually has many advantages
over democracy father of the king runs
the kingdom and then he passes it on to
his son who passes it on to the grandson
there's a long-term interest then in the
Integrity of that Society the Baker and
the blacksmith Etc I'm aligned with them
because they're passing their businesses
on in a hereditary fashion too you don't
want to overtax the population because
they will revolt and kill you because
it's very clear who runs the monarchy
you don't want to go to war too much
because you will bankrupt the monarchy
your son wouldn't would not inherit
anything and so there's kind of this
system of checks and balances in this
long-term orientation and when you
contrast that to democracy we vote these
people into power for four to eight
years they cut as many deals as they can
to get as many Kickbacks and then they
just check out of office and pass all
that on to the next guy there's an
incentive for short-termism and
plundering that exists in democracy that
does not exist inside of a monarchy